you said that I love rock and roll quote
I love folk I love jazz I love Indian
classical music I really love all kinds
of music as long as it's authentic and
from the heart so when you play Rock
versus Jazz you played all kinds of
music uh what's the difference
technically musically spiritually for
you well there's no spiritual difference
okay right cross that off the list but
uh more musically yeah like it's kind of
like what was saying earli it's like
each
genre has its language of
what makes it that
genre um and th that would be a good
thing to say it's defined by the you
know the dos and don'ts um because yeah
it's
like I'm trying to
think basically I put the song first and
I think of the song as the melody the
lyrics
and then the Harmony and obviously the
groove so the song goes before the genre
in a sense each each song is like its
own thing they're both things that are
held in my mind it's like okay genre and
then song which is comprised of those
basic you know
elements
um and I tend to kind of prioritize
lyric because somebody is trying to
express something over music and so that
uh the lyric is very very
important and so then the choices come
from there it's like okay within the
genre of X um this is the typical
language and then how do I best serve
this this lyric and
then where else can I pull from that
might not be in these two bags that
would put a little twist on it mhm so
those are all the kinds of things I
might be thinking about um but I don't
like twists for the sake of twists
either I like twists
because I want to hear something that
might be
fresh but when someone does something
just to be hip it's annoying to me you I
think you can hear the difference it's
like when people like they write in odd
time signatures or like They Ride all
these riffs just because they can just
because they have the chops to do it or
they know how to play in 1116 and
whatever but it's like but if it's not
actually creating a piece of music
that's going to move somebody then why
are you doing it and so I think a lot of
the questions I'm asking myself when I'm
approaching a song are mainly
philosophical and
aesthetic so you like to stand on the
edge of the cliff not not for the thrill
of it but cuz that's where you find
something new yeah potentially yeah and
it's thrilling but you're not doing it
just for the thrill I'm not doing it for
the thrill it just happens to be
thrilling all right because you can
always reel it back
in can you though yeah you can no you
can like do a totally like disciplined
like I can go into a session and okay my
favorite thing about going into a
session with with musicians that I adore
is that we don't hear the demo cuz if
you hear a demo you're hearing what the
producer or songwriter have already
imagined that every instrument is
playing and then it's like well I've
already heard what you want now my mind
is part of my mind is focused on what I
already know you want what the
destination going to be why did you
bring me in here I want to not hear it I
just want you to set at a piano and sing
the song with the I want to hear the
chords and the lyric and or sit in
acoustic to play it and then let's all
go in the room and then take One MH I
would say 80% of the time take one has
the most gold and there might be like a
mistake or two or someone forgot to go
to the B section and you might want to
like punch that in so that you're
hitting the right cord but all the magic
is in that take and then sometimes it
happens where it's like you go it's like
we're rehearsing and take one two three
four five and then you're like thinking
about it too much and then you go and
you have a dinner and you come back and
the next take one after dinner is the
one like it's usually after there's some
sort of a break MH that but but OB
obviously there's exceptions to that
rule sometimes it take two and three
yeah you said uh you said that this is
something that surprised you about
recording with Prince is that he would
just so much of it would be take
one so quick it would just move so
quickly yeah well with that particular
album that we made together it's called
Welcome to America he called me up and
asked me he said I want to make a band
with you I'm like really inspired by
what you're doing with Jeff Beck I want
to make a trio do you like the drum
rolls of Jack D Janette was like his
first question to me I'm like well yeah
who doesn't who doesn't like Jack D
Janette like one of the greatest of all
time and he's like well you know uh
sounds like because we had a discussion
about drummy sound sounds like you're
you're kind of particular about drummers
so why don't you find us the drummer and
I'll trust you to find the drummer you
can audition some people send me some
recordings and maybe two favorites and
I'll pick pick out of the two or
something so I did that went on a
journey found a couple guys he picked
the one we went in and
um he basically
just would be like okay so the a section
is going to go like this and then the B
section I think we're going to go to uh
G and du du and then the bridge I might
go to B flat but maybe I'll hold off and
okay let's go one two three four and
then we recorded it to tape there was no
punch he did not want me to punch
anything like it was like and there was
one song called um same page different
book MH and and he like talked through
it just like he did and then he had me
soloing between each phrase like little
fills like I I didn't know that that was
going to come up and that and he loved
that he loved that to have me on the
edge of my seat M like falling off the
cliff that was my first like real like
falling off a Cliff moment from somebody
else holding me at the edge of the cliff
you know what I mean um now I just do it
on my own because it's so it's so fun
and makes sense it's it's the best thing
for the music when you say punch the
tape that that when you actually record
it like if you record to tape and
there's like say like you hit a bum note
like to to punch in means to like fix
that note like re-record over that one
little area and and punch punch that
note in he didn't want that he like he's
like all my favorite records just like
whatever happened happened that's that
moment in time let's make a new moment
in time it's great nobody makes records
like that
anymore everyone wants to like you know
edit and edit and re-record and this and
that and unfortunately with a lot of
music and I'm not saying all music
because there's plenty of great music
coming out but the there's the danger of
it being flat mhm because because every
little imperfection
is is digitally removed well that's one
of the promising things about AI is
because it can be so perfect that the
thing will actually come back to and
value about music is the imperfections
that humans can create yeah there would
be a greater valuation of imperfections
yeah I mean you can kind of program
imperfections too yeah sure that's
that's also very sad but then you get
closer and closer to what it means to be
human and maybe there'll be AI Among Us
they'll be human flawed like the rest of
us mortal and silly at
times